i go out the riviera because if they
value either way they're gonna
send you to the line but yonescu
fellaini you want to see them with the
ball
ball inbound to kylie shook four seconds
left ginesco a long three for the win
and she gets it
sabrina unesco at the buzzer
.4 seconds left
sabrina unesco from downtown
and the liberty have a three-point lead
my goodness
we've got ourselves a bowler on the new
york liberty
she is a game time clutch
player and if i've ever seen a clutch
shot
that is so sad so hurt
you've seen her do it in college look at
that she turns
she sets her feet so nice the bench
loves it
did you see victoria vivian's face on
the fever bench
she tells him to go back to the bench
look at her she's trying not to smile
if we can get another look at that
replay that was pretty that
oh my goodness sabrina yanesco
ice in her veins but point four left
gotta think about the trent tucker rule
point three
five nothing run to end the game all by
unesco she scored the last eight
liberty points
tiffany mitchell for three for the tie
no good
and the liberty win the season opener
here at barclay center
by three thanks to sethrina
yanescu ice in her veins as she
knocks it down finishes with 25 points
11 assists six rebounds four shy of a
triple double
benigelani enyanescu combined to score
55 of the liberty 90 points
what a game jules this is the kind of
transcendent star that just goes so well
in new york the biggest market in the
wnba i mean look at that
shot beautiful shot by unesco and what
about this play i love this play
this draw up by walt hopkins this was
what you kind of expected
who would see the basketball and she she
took care of business
trying to get sabrina sabrina can you
hear us can you hear us yes i can
sabrina what's going through your mind
when you take that last shot there i
wanted it
um i haven't played in a while i wanted
it for this team we grinded out a huge
win here and just so happy to have fans
family here in attendance and
it's just the beginning for us sabrina
just described this first game back i
mean it's been 10 11 months since you've
really seen the court
what was it like you felt you looked
like you felt so comfortable out there
i'm just excited to get back to playing
and doing what i love you know my team
supported me my coaching staff this
entire organization and
this is what i love doing the highs and
lows you know everything through it
this really pays off sabrina talk about
the way that
preseason has been for you i mean this
has been a newer team a newer lineup
you've got a player like benigalani
who was tremendous tonight what's it
like playing with someone like her
where you know you can go to her at any
moment she played unbelievable tonight i
think everyone did
you know every single player that
checked in everybody that didn't we
needed everyone tonight and
she's a phenomenal player you know
playing against her was tough and i'm
just so happy she's on our team now
just two wins last year for this team
sabrina you only played three games but
what's the significance of getting this
one
out of the way in the first game we
needed this at home
you know in front of these fans in front
of everybody here i haven't won
a part of this organization yet going
down last year and so this one's going
to be special but
there's a lot more you know a lot more
wins coming for us sabrina thank you so
much for the time and congratulations on
the win
thank you very much thanks sabrina all
right jules we're going to step aside
take a break but we'll come back to wrap
things up how about another look
at the hero for the new york liberty
tonight
sabrina yanescu
oh boy sabrina's feeling it she loved
being back out there the joy of the game
just flows through her veins and her
teammates are excited to have her
on their side